these first four we should pretty much
be able to just rattle off when it gets
here and when it starts to get a little
tricky
okay so I've asked you to do two things
factorize and then to solve so before we
get to the solutions for each one which
I'm sure some of you already have let's
get the factorization and then we'll get
the two answers for each one okay
good morning committee so who wants to
see their hand up give me the first
factorization for number one
any takers any takers what are we going
to get when we write this good morning
anyone yep X plus 4 and X plus 7 perfect
and we chose four and seven correctly
because foreign seven happen to this
survive and they multiplied to this
number if you ever struggle to remember
which ones which length do I multiply
this one how do you remember which ones
finish I tend to remember it like this
you've seen quite a lot of these
questions like you'll see hundreds and
hundreds of them write this number along
the end almost always is a big number
it's usually a very big number or at
least it's usually big compared to this
guy right and so it's easier to get big
numbers by multiplying them versus
adding so that's how I remember this is
usually a way that you multiply two also
in this particular example there aren't
many covers that multiply to give you 11
in fact there are only two one and
eleven those whole numbers anyway so you
like if you get to try and find up as
that both might of these you quickly
realize this is not working out okay so
four and seven they add to 11 a multiply
228 that's perfect you could go
backwards expand this out and get your
original question right
so I factorized now what do I do to
actually solve for hey what am I gonna
do to solve this yeah okay okay what am
I going to multiply
okay so if I wanted to you if I want to
expand on 30 X times X that it could be
the x squared X by 7 and reach my four
there before X 7x that are gonna be 11
etc that will expand but I want to solve
I want the values that would make this
true I have to help me out good so in
case you didn't catch like why would you
even do that right
if you've got two numbers right this
number and this number and when you
multiply them together because there's a
multiplication sign is just hiding in
there right we just don't write it okay
if you've got two numbers and you
multiply them together and you get zero
at least one of the numbers has to be
zero right
like there's no pair of numbers where
one of them is a zero that will give you
this result so if you say maybe let's
take the first one make that zero if X
plus 4 equals zero then what will xp-
far very good that's what I get from
here or alternatively I said it could be
the other one
right so if we're this guy over here if
X plus seven equals zero then you're
gonna get negative seven okay by the way
just a little little side don't forget
your pressure did I put the whip or
there I think that's a good idea
I don't like putting a comma because
when you put a comma it's like well what
what what do you actually leave is the
relationship between these do you need
or do me and do you mean like what's the
combination between them it's all it's
not in because you can't be minus 4
minus 7 at the same time unless you're
some weird shredder you subtract things
so might as well all my 2/7 those reps
you swishes do you have a question yeah
so once one of them you've like made
zero
you're gone could not going to be
anything correct that's right in fact
let's just test that one happens like
for example I take this solution right x
equals negative 4 when you pop it in
here this part becomes zero right
this part does not it becomes negative 4
plus 7 which is 3 but my check right but
0 times 3 I don't care what this guy is
it could be 0 times 38 could be 0 times
50 it could be 0 times rockmelon it's
still going to give you 0
at the end right so therefore I'm happy
a community away there are my two
solutions we did that a little slowly
let's see if we can do the next one's a
bit quicker numbered suit again give me
the factorization and then we'll go
straight to answer someone who hasn't
said anything yet how are we gonna
factorize this you're looking for a pair
of numbers right add to this multiply
this yes okay plus 6 and minus threes
are gonna work for us
six take away three does give me three
six times 83 does give me negative 18 so
it's gonna work so I'm gonna go to X
plus 6x take three okay you're happy
with that but that's just the
factorization what's the solution
yeah I'm gonna do that same make these
things equal to zero business right
another way of looking at it is I'm just
gonna take the opposite of these numbers
here right so I'm gonna go to six from
there or three from this guy you happy
with that and again one of the ways we
can know always with equations is if
these solutions are correct you can pop
them back into this original equation
and it'll work I should be able to do it
with both of them right so for instance
let's take three that's a smaller number
so it'd be easier to test right let's
see what happens if I give it a shot 3
squared is 9 plus 3 times 3 which is
also 9 9 plus 9 is 18 you take away 18
and sure enough you get 0 it satisfies
the original equation and you can test
that with negative 6 as well it's gonna
check out all right number 3 got another
negative flying around there okay so
when we go for our factorization pair of
numbers adds to this multiplies to this
yeah
X minus 2x minus 10 perfect okay it's
gonna check out the atom you get minus
12
you multiply them and the negatives
cancel don't they okay so out of this I
just read off my solutions right what
value makes this 0 2 and the day that
makes this 0 is 2 okay
last easy one before it's tough to get a
bit more involved
this guy here what pair of numbers do I
want the the pair of numbers I want on 3
& 3 3 & 3 right cuz if you do 3 plus 3
you get 6 and if you do 3 times 3 you'll
get 9 so I can write this in two
different ways
I could write it as 3 & 3 that'll do it
right or alternatively I could write
that all in one go I could say that's
just X plus 3 squared are you happy with
that
ok being that is only really one thing
here that I can make 0 I only get one
solution out of this namely thank you
free most things there we go okay all
right so that's getting you in the back
of the space of the quadratics you've
been doing before because if you
remember just put this in different
color you at the front here these X
Squared's right how many X squares have
I got in each of these first four
questions I've just got the one right
there's a one hiding in each question
okay so because there's just one we call
these guys monic quadratics money as in
like like I want to call like someone's
or monorail or one or anything yeah
single right but these guys are not
Manik right so we call them money
preventative isn't it so how we going to
do bees I just got to look at these very
briefly at the end of last Thursday's
lesser so if you can't remember it or
you see these before and you're like
okay these freaked me out a little bit
let me walk you through it again
question five okay actually they would
just quickly get a show of here's how
people have attempted five six or seven
heads up straight
a decent number of you I can't good
hands down what we do fine I'll just
write out the question first and if
you're in the large number of people who
haven't put their hand up yet either
because of time or you just not sure how
to start follow along with me and why
did you this is a very similar way to
how I did it before okay and I showed
you this very briefly last Thursday I
again what a pair of numbers right but
it's fit instead of a pair of numbers
but adds to this and multiplies this I
want a pair of numbers that adds to this
13 and multiplies to this the product of
these two numbers that's 12 okay so I'm
just gonna write that down beside so you
have an idea of what my thought process
is
I want nerve is that something plus
something equals 30 and something times
something equals 12
okay so I've picked out an easy tip for
this first one
what's the pair of numbers that will
satisfy this 12 one right that'll do it
as well plus one so he'll plus 1/12
times one sorry okay so checks out now
what do I do with those numbers okay
when I go up to here we use 12 and one
and break them apart
right so this 13 X is really made of a
12 X and a 1 it okay now I've got to
look carefully how I write this is a
couple of different ways I can write it
I'm going to write it like this okay
I've put the 12 X first and I put the
One X second you'll see why I've done
that in a second if you accidentally did
it the wrong way around it's okay all is
not lost you'll just run into a brick
wall and realize you've got to come back
here okay I'll show you in a minute now
that I do have it in the right order I
can see I have a pair of terms here
which I can factorize and then I'll have
a pair of terms here that if I've picked
the numbers right and goes victim it
looks good to me
okay it will also fit together with what
we get at the minute so have a look at
this guy what can i factor out this pair
of terms
I can take out a 3 for both of these and
I can also take out an X for both just
the 1 right so I'll write that 3x out
the front ok now what does that leave me
with
after I factorize it out by then Leslie
I can mix and when I divide the 12 X I
get a plus 4 aha
tic that's how I know I've done it right
because that X plus 4 matches with this
X plus 4 along the end I'm just going to
write one extra theme see how just like
over here I've got x squared x squared X
when x squared really there's a 1 hiding
in all of those spots okay
there's also one hiding here see that
how many X plus 4 s are there here
there's just one of them ok now that I
know there's just one of them these two
terms I can factorize again you see how
they both have that X plus 4 so I Chuck
that X plus 4 out the front when I bring
that out what does that leave me with
it's a 3 X there and there's possible
there that's my factorization BAM ok so
that was the hard part we had to invest
a lot more effort to get to this
factorization versus these ones right
that's because these ones are a little
more complicated but now that I've
factorized it looks just like the other
questions right I want either this thing
to equal 0 that would give me a solution
or I want this thing to equal 0
either of those will give me an answer
that works ok so from the first one well
that is good to do that no uniform this
one's going to give me a fraction this
is a little bit Messier right but you
can see what I need to do if you
struggle to do it in your head at the
moment that's alright if I would just
gave you that is the question what would
I do
guess I'll take that one over the other
side that would give me this you're
happy with that and then what I need to
do to solve I divide both sides by 3
right which gives me by this one
okay so that's my other solution or - a
Fed okay